pour vous il y a trop d'immigrés en
France aujourd'hui c'est les Français
qui le disent vous citer les sondages un
qui est paru dans le Figaro au doxa 74%
des Français disent qu'il y a trop
d'immigrés alors il y en a 92 % dans ma
famille politique mais il y en a 52% au
Parti socialiste ça veut dire que quel
que soit les appartenances politiques il
y a aujourd'hui ce sentiment ce
sentiment il faut l'entendre parce que
on ne fait rien depuis des années en
tout cas on ne fait pas ce qu'il faut
parce que il y a une forme d'élite qui
dit regardez il y a rien à voir on ne
peut pas faire ça puis c'est pas bien et
si contre la vie des français donc c'est
pour ça que au cœur de notre projet on
dit mais c'est au français décidé nous
on veut réformer la Constitution parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des obstacles et
les Français décideront par référendum
si on le laisse faire par le Parlement
par l'Assemblée le Sénat il y aura
toujours ses obstacles des obstacles
médiatiques ceux qui savent et qui vont
imposer leur point de vue moi je veux
qu'on donne la parole aux Français alors
selon la définition de l'Insee un
immigré est une personne née étrangère à
l'étranger et résidant en France le taux
de la population immigré en 2021 était
de 10,3%
pourquoi aujourd'hui pourquoi
l'immigration poserait un si gros
problème parce que
c'est le problème de l'intégration être
étranger quand on adhère on épouse les
valeurs du pays qui vous accueillent ne
pose aucun aucune difficulté aujourd'hui
le nombre d'étrangers qui sont arrivés
en un accueil en situation légale
quasiment 500 000 chaque année 500 000
chaque année qui ceux qui se rajoutent
et donc aujourd'hui on n'a plus la
capacité à assimiler aux valeurs de la
République ces personnes à ce qu'elles
puissent tout travailler il y a 500 000
étrangers au chômage à ce qu'elles
puissent connaître la langue de la
République et puis il y a des problèmes
de communautarisme on l'a vu qui sont
liés à cette immigration de masse il y a
des problèmes de délinquance c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est le ministre de
l'Intérieur puisque il a été je le dis
presque courageusement le premier à
faire ce lien il a pas fait grand chose
pour mais à dire il y a un lien entre
délinquance et immigration 24% des
détenus en prison aujourd'hui sont des
étrangers vous avez cité le chiffre à
peu près 7% de la population
alors sur les étranges vous parlez des
immigrés sur les étrangers c'est presque
8 3 millions 3 millions 5 millions il y
en a 24% donc trois fois plus
proportionnellement en prison donc il y
a ce lien
90% des vols à l'attire dans les
transports parisiens sont commis par des
étrangers donc il y a un sujet il faut
qu'on intègre mieux ce qui sont ici il
faut que ceux qui n'ont pas le droit d'y
être repartent chez eux et il faut qu'on
arrête que notre pays accueille trop
d'étrangers j'étais hier au Danemark le
Danemark il a envoyé un message très
clair en disant on ne peut pas
accueillir certaines personnes et donc
ils ne seront pas bien accueillis ici et
du coup ils vont ailleurs ce message de
dissuasion comporter les Danois au-delà
des mesures qui sont en application ils
ont lancé un message ce message il a été
entendu nous en gros on dit c'est open
bar vous avez les prestations sociales
dès le premier jour les allocations
familiales vous avez une multitude
d'aide médicale d'État vous avez le
droit aujourd'hui de venir vous soigner
en France parce que dans votre pays il
n'y a pas le même niveau de soin tout ça
c'est une forme de naïveté les Français
ne l'acceptent plus et ça nuit à la
cohésion de notre pays
moi ce que j'aime bien monsieur Scotti
c'est que vous n'êtes pas langue de bois
et là vous l'êtes moins que jamais c'est
à dire que là vous faites directement
explicitement le lien entre immigration
et délinquance c'est pas moi ce sont les
statistiques vous dites sur le plateau
s'il y avait moins d'immigrés
aujourd'hui il y aurait moins
d'insécurité ou de sentiments
d'insécurité en France moins
d'insécurité directement les immigrés
sont responsables de l'insécurité
majoritairement en tout cas c'est pas
moi qui l'ai dit hein je le solide
mais je le confirme le préfet de police
de Paris l'ancien préfet de police le
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
Darmanin n'est pas dans la même famille
politique il partent sur les bases de
les du service statistique du ministère
de l'Intérieur
il dit oui on y était mais on n'y est
plus 50% des actes de délinquance commis
à Paris à Lyon à Marseille donc dans les
grandes villes sont aujourd'hui du fait
d'étrangers c'est une statistique après
chacun y trouve son interprétation mais
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui très
clairement notre pays n'a plus la
capacité à accueillir autant d'étrangers
parce qu'elle n'a plus la capacité à les
intégrer comme il conviendrait et tous
les immigrés qui travaillent dans la
restauration dans des tas de secteurs
qui sans eux ne fonctionnerait plus
aujourd'hui monsieur sautier
moi je suis plus favorable à
l'immigration de travail
qu'à l'immigration familiale ou
quelquefois aussi
oh au dévoiement du droit d'asile qui
permet de faire rentrer aujourd'hui
chaque année 130 000 personnes dont
environ 80 000 sont des faux demandeurs
d'asile ils utilisent vous voulez pas de
regroupement familial alors je veux
limiter le regroupement familial nous ce
que nous proposons ce sont des plafonds
maximum qui est une forme de quota
aujourd'hui on a l'année dernière on a
donné 320 330 000 titres de séjour en
France nous disons il faut il faut pas
dépasser je prends un exemple c'est pas
un chiffre qui a arrêté mais on ferait
voter chaque année par le Parlement
plafondisant cette année on dépasse pas
les 75000 et là dedans il y en a 15000
pour le regroupement familial il y a 40
000 étudiants il y en a 30 000 qui
viennent travailler enfin j'ai pas le
compte je sais pas s'il est exact voilà
et donc
ceux qui arrivent au-delà du seuil ils
attendent l'année d'après mais le
regroupement familial aujourd'hui il est
automatique il est automatique parce que
on doit subir la règle qui nous a
imposée par un article d'une convention
internationale et d'ailleurs dans notre
proposition de loi nous disons si les
Français le décident aucune normes
internationale ne pourra être supérieur
à la volonté du peuple pour vous la loi
immigration elle est
une urgence à la faire pour vous bien
sûr parce que la situation elle est
grave on voit bien que tous les chiffres
se dégradent jamais nous n'avons
accueilli autant d'étrangers dans notre
pays jamais autant chaque année c'est
l'équivalent d'une très grande ville
de certains talents de certains mais on
les choisit comment on les choisit il y
a pour choisir un bon immigré qui qui
quitte son pays parce qu'il y a la
famille mais qui arrive en France qui va
travailler à un mauvais immigré qui
quitte son pays qui va profiter des
aides qui a foutent nos bordel ici
seulement on différencie quand il est
sur le bateau en pleine mer comment on
sait lequel est le bon lequel est le
mauvais lequel on garde dans lequel on
vient mais bon on laisse le bateau c'est
pas le bon vecteur
c'est pas le bon vecteur pour arriver si
on veut arriver on va faire une demande
de visa dans un consulat à l'étranger il
y a des cartes talons qui s'appelle
talents et compétences notamment pour
accueillir des professionnels de santé
il y en a donc moi je dis je préfère une
immigration de travail mais légale vous
parliez tout à l'heure dans les
restaurants je pense que c'est un peu le
projet de Monsieur Darmanin c'est pour
ça qu'on est contre c'est il veut
régulariser ce qui travaille au noir
ceux qui sont des clandestins ça je m'y
refuse parce que si on commence à
régulariser comme c'est fait aujourd'hui
il y a 30 000 clandestins environ chaque
année qui sont régularisés ça veut dire
quoi on lance un message à tous ceux qui
veulent venir et qui vont se dire une
fois qu'on a mis un pied en France en
Europe puis en France on est régularisé
ça ça marche pas
je souhaite qu'on le rétablissements
c'est le problème pour vous est-ce que
c'est l'immigration ou l'immigration de
clandestine parce que avec ce qu'a dit
Raymond on est là dessus
c'est naturellement l'immigration
l'immigration clandestine d'abord 800
000 à peu près 800 000 1 million
étrangers en situation
irrégulières sur le territoire national
tous les jours à la frontière italienne
chez moi dans les Alpes-Maritimes 2 à
300 étrangers en situation irrégulière
interpellé ramener en Italie puis
reviennent mais le problème aussi il
faut avoir le courage de le dire c'est
l'immigration légale qu'on ne contrôle
pas ou en gros en gros aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de politique migratoire
presque tous ceux qui veulent venir en
France sont accueillis
c'est une question de temps tous ceux
qui sont même en situation illégale ne
sont que très rarement renvoyés 5%
environ de ceux qui sont en situation
illégale c'est la fameuse histoire des
aucutaires les obligations de quitter le
territoire français avec des drames
terrifiants ou chaque fois on découvre
qu'une personne a commis un crime un
délit il y a eu l'affaire Lola et que
ces personnes étaient sous l'objet d'une
occf non exécuté
50000 au qtf il y en a moins de 10000
qui sont exécutés donc la réalité elle
est là donc il y a les deux sujets trop
d'immigrations légales et pas de
régulation de contrôle suffisant
l'immigration illégale on manque de
structures érgées au Danemark Danemark
ils ont mis des centres il y a une
agence du retour qui organise le retour
et ceux qui arrivent notamment les
demandeurs d'asile pendant que leur
demande est examinée ils sont dans des
centres de très grandes réalité il y a
il y a une forme de confort c'est pas
une prison mais si leur demande pour
obtenir le statut de réfugiés c'est
noble d'obtenir le statut de réfugiés
c'est l'honneur de la France et des pays
développés de protéger ceux qui sont
opprimés chez lui chez eux et bien s'ils
ont pas ce statut ils sont renvoyés
immédiatement nous on le fait pas c'est
5% des déboutés du droit d'asile donc
dès qu'on est ici et tout ça ça donne du
grain à moudre aux filières de passeur
qui vendent le passage en Méditerranée
et ça nourrit les drames parce que il y
a cette forme de naïveté ou un accueil
et où on ne renvoie pas c'est quoi cette
histoire de double peine c'est ce c'est
la double peine la double peine c'est
dire que quand on est étranger en France
connaît condamné à une peine de plus de
1 an de prison ferme il y a ce qu'on
appelle une interdiction territoire
français c'est une peine complémentaire
c'est la justice qu'il prononce et puis
après les autorités administratives les
préfets en prennent acte et 10 vous avez
vous êtes arrivé en France vous aviez
des papiers vous avez déchiré le contrat
parce que venir en France ça donne des
des droits mais il faut aussi des
devoirs et le premier de ses devoirs ce
n'est pas de commettre un crime un délit
à fortiori un crime donc vous avez
commis un acte de délinquants vous avez
rompu le contrat avec la République avec
la France qui vous a fait l'honneur vous
accueillir vous repartez c'est la prison
et l'avion pour vous qui veulent
vraiment le dire voilà est-ce que vous
êtes pour la double peine comme le vient
de le dire Erik sottiquer pour qui est
content
complètement je ne comprends même pas
comment on a pu la supprimer quel est
l'intérêt de garder des gens qui
justement rompent ce contrat et qui sont
des dangers
quelle était la motivation moi je me
souviens plus mais quelle était la
motivation pour supprimer cette double
peine à part de l'idéologie ou
en tout cas aujourd'hui c'est contenu de
l'évolution de la délinquance de la
criminalité de ce lien que
malheureusement je m'en réjouis pas on
constate aujourd'hui il faut être lucide
il faut envoyer un message on ne peut
pas s'attaquer aux valeurs de la
République on peut pas commettre un
délit quand un pays vous accueille un
Français qui fait ça à l'étranger il
reste pas voilà donc il faut qu'il y ait
la réciprocité moi je suis pas du tout
d'accord et là vous faites la chasse aux
immigrés clandestins illégaux et
Monsieur Ciotti vous savez là je parle
de ceux qui tombaient
tu peux on va rappeler ce que c'est en
situation
qui a commis
un crime voilà c'est ça je prends un an
plus
et que ce qui récidive je prends je
prends un exemple
il y avait
un étranger en situation régulière qui
avait
mis le feu à la cathédrale de Nantes
ce drame et qui ensuite a assassiner le
prêtre qu'il hébergeait voilà donc il
aurait parce que il y avait il y avait
cette incendie il aurait dû être expulsé
automatiquement il n'a pas été voilà
c'est ce à quoi s'attaque de façon très
concrète nos propositions de loi c'est
une question de bon sens sauf que vous
savez que ça peut susciter aussi des
crises diplomatiques parce qu'il y a les
pays qui ne veulent pas les récupérer
une crise diplomatique avec je ne sais
pas
il y a beaucoup de pays d'origine qui ne
veulent pas reprendre le ressortissant
là c'est une action diplomatique c'est
une action politique il faut dire à ces
pays donnant-donnant il y a des visas
qu'on leur accorde façon importante il y
a des laissés passer consulaires alors
le gouverne le gouvernement l'avait dit
puis il a reculé notamment vis-à-vis de
l'Algérie donc aujourd'hui l'Algérie ne
reprend quasiment personne quasiment
personne alors que le président Macron a
donné des signes voilà et puis l'Algérie
il y a aussi des accords bilatéraux
notamment qui existent depuis 68 qu'il
faudra sans doute revoir parce qu'ils
sont d'une live tu es incroyable
l'Algérie en permanence nous attaquent
nous insultent et puis nous on dit mais
venez non mais tout ça c'est pas
réaliste